(screaming)
- Hi, my name is Inez Laval,
I'm an Esthetician, and
today I'll be waxing
women's arms for the first time.
- We are hairy girls.
- I mean if this is
stuff that women do, like
I'm willing to give it a shot.
I might like the way it feels.
- The difference between eight year old me
who was made fun of for being hairy,
and then me today, choosing
to get my arms waxed,
is that I want to do it for
myself and as a personal
experience and not because
I'm under any pressure to.
I can't wait to like put
silky sheets on my bed--
- Ooooh!
- And make them completely smooth and--
- I didn't even--
- like swim around.
- Think about that.
- Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Okay, on shoot.
Oh my God, yes, yes.
- Thank you for being here with me.
It's so hot.
Oh no, wait is this happening yet?
- [Voiceover] Hold my hand, hold my hand.
- I'm sorry for peeking.
- Ahh, ahh, ah ha.
- Jessica.
- It's fine, it's not that bad actually,
it's definitely not that bad.
The wax kind of feels good now.
Alright, that wasn't that bad at all.
Do you wanna give me your
hand or you good or--
- Yea.
Eww, ooo, ooo oh,
I'm so hairy, oh my God.
Oh my God you're right like
it doesn't feel like my arm.
- [Voiceover] Silky sheets.
- Silky sheets, I can't
wait for silky sheets.
That was crazy.
- We did it, high five.
- We did it.
I'm actually like really
excited about the look.
I feel like I'm gonna be more
confident wearing tank tops,
and my dresses like this.
- I didn't have that much
hair on me, but I've never
waxed anything, so that
was definitely like
a learning experience,
and I'm so, you talked
about the silky bed.
- Silky bed.
- I am so ready.